okay so let me explain a little more
about our tress from what we know so
here's what here's what they say the
value proposition is that you can buy
fine art in installments so you were
saying masterworks lets you buy a piece
of a piece of art they sort of
fractionalized it these guys say it's
yours but you can hear on a monthly
payment plan this has been a big trend
in e-commerce anybody who's been paying
attention to a firm or after pay these
are multi-billion dollar companies that
are just saying even low-priced items
right here's a $40 item but you can buy
it in four easy installments and a firm
is doing quite well both of those
companies are gonna go public or it's
looking like they will right after
perhaps you already public and firm is I
think going to go public and so there
and there's there's more sizzle there's
there's others that are doing this too
so that's a very good business to be in
I believe and so so that's what these
guys are doing they said we've sold
thirty six thousand dollars worth of art
in three weeks this is unlike a firm and
unlike after paid they're not a payment
option on other market other websites
they are their own marketplace and so
what they're trying to do is they give
artists the ability to sell their work
they say most artists don't even sell
their work so they say listed here we
offer people the ability to buy in
instalments so more people can buy so
we've more buyers in our pool and they
they get the artist to put their link to
their store just like an Etsy store in
their bio so they put their art in res
link at the bio and that's driving a lot
of users because these are you know
Instagram artists are artists with an
Instagram who have you know a hundred
thousand followers and they're getting
them to buy of all these different
artists and that's going to drive
traffic that's a lot how SoundCloud grew
early on was going for these independent
artists and then saying cool we'll give
you an easy way to host your artwork in
that case music but you know here at
share your SoundCloud profile and that's
how they got tons of traffic and built
up their marketplace and so I think
that's what these guys are trying to do
I think this is smart the art market is
one of those markets that's bigger than
you think because you don't even you
don't even learn about it till you're
already rich and what's already rich you
don't do start a company in it and so I
think it's one of those big invisible
market
to most entrepreneurs who are scrappy
and don't own you know like a pencil let
alone a piece of or I so I would have
agreed with you and before you start
talking I agreed that it was great but
then you the way you described it if
okay so I would I would be against it if
Etsy is competent they can destroy these
guys yeah I think it's gonna be hard
though because ed sees niche is handmade
crafts and I think that's just
fundamentally different than fine art I
think when you it's like putting a
bottle of wine next to a Budweiser right
in the aisle it's it's a little bit I
don't think the people who want their
art to be sold or fine art to be sold or
want to buy want to be next to somebody
who's making bracelets that would be my
that'd be my bare case against that okay
I buy that I buy that but oh okay I get
it so I see a painting on here it's
three thousand dollars I could pay
overtime for for 24 months for a hundred
and thirty-seven dollars okay so my
question is this is this pay overtime
feature even that unique enough to build
most your company on top of why not just
like have a normal art store and just
uninstall a firm yeah that's a good
question I don't know why they're not
just using one of the existing
installment plans you know why are they
why are they owning that piece of it
it's like an art marketplace but then
also this financing program when they
could just use one of the existing
financing programs so I'm looking at it
now yeah I I'm changing my mind it's
stupid okay well we'll see jury's out on
on art and res I'm not an expert in this
area but I'm sure something there my bet
would be I think marketplaces are really
really freaking hard to start and and so
I for that reason I think that it's
going to be incredibly difficult and
they definitely have done that yet but
you know so I would say odds are always
against any marketplace being successful
but I do like the fundamentals of what
they're trying to do I don't think this
is a stupid I don't think this is a
stupid bet to take if you're an
entrepreneur but I do think still
likelihood is that it doesn't work like
most startups I think that a
but there's a difference here of working
and just building the wealth and then
working by raising money no I mean the
business working no not the reason money
lots of companies can raise money yeah
but what I mean is should I think this
for sure can make a living for
the owners the question is is if they
raise money then will it work or will it
not my prediction is if they raise money
it's gonna fail I feel like that's your
prediction with most things I think you
just don't like what people raise money
for the most part no the next one that
we're going to talk about carrot I think
that could work
[Music]